Lucca why did you remake this movie this
was a you've wanted to do this for like
72 percent of your life yeah
in fact I I have to be honest I think
that much of my life has been stalking
in my mind that and not only that you're
gentle I remember I was a kid I went to
Rome and because I had to do something I
come from Palermo Sicily I had to do
some medical thing and I begged the
friend of my mom to drive me all the way
to the element Z knee which is almost
like Santa Monica Boulevard to go up and
down and find on all the doors the name
that you're gentle because I knew he was
living there so basically I think this
is a sort of ultimate act of love for
value for you and for Tilda this has
been discussed for some time this was
not something that you've decided to do
over a weekend why the what appeal to
you about the original Suspiria this is
for both of you and then and then
because the original has a very very
different ending I'm curious whether the
I'll I'm glad we're talking about it
after the movie because oh I can so did
it Northpoint it in well but they've
they have they've had 41 years to see
the original but so was the was your
original idea I'm gonna remake this
movie and we are and we're gonna make
Susie part of it
well the various film is when you see
the four at the age of fourteen it's
like it's a punch but it's a good punch
like it it wakes you up and I was very
serious about the movie not only I love
the let's say formal qualities of the
film but I was invested in in the movie
in the story in this in this world of
witches and in the coven being also a
related to dance so I I really I don't
know it strikes something very strong in
me and with all the things we love
somehow we want to possess them and
that's how I wanted to make it into a
movie but we never talked about it as a
remake we always I always described as
as a cover and you know nobody
a song that they don't love and nobody
tries I mean unless they're you know two
sandwiches short of a picnic tries to
make it exactly the same as the the
original and also there are so many
countless covers of Hamlet and fastest
and whatever else it felt like it was a
provocation Dario's film and it just you
know it was like a like a homeopathic
treatment it kinda got it got the juices
flowing I mean it was the poster that
actually I would say maybe made Luca
filmmaker in the first place
forget the film it was the poster is
that right yeah yeah I thought when I
was then very impressive
this body this blood the severed head
Jessica have you ever seen the the first
one tell tell tell those who may not
know what your connection to the
original Suspiria is the original
Suspiria I played the part of Suzie 41
years ago but who's counting did you you
got a phone call from from Luca how did
you learn that that there was interest
in have and that there would be a remake
in that they were interested in having
you in well I've been hearing for a long
time not a remake cover and mumbling
about doing another version of Suspiria
for years and I kept hearing different
directors names associated with I never
paid much attention because as you know
in Hollywood these things seldom happen
so but then I heard that there that that
Luca was associated that he wanted to
make a Suspiria and that just seemed to
me like an excellent idea I was a big
fan of his films and I thought you know
trying to imagine how he would put his
imprint on this material just filled me
with joy so then I got a phone call from
Luca and he said hi Jessica would you
like to do a cameo
in my Suspiria and i said well he had me
at hello I just said absolutely and then
I and then he said can you can you do
the part in German and I said of course
I can and then we hung up and I went to
the Berlitz school as quickly as I
possibly could and said I would like to
learn German this afternoon do you think
you can accommodate me so that's the
rest is history
Chloe and Mia what was your how did you
get drawn into the project did you guys
have any experience with the with the
first version I had Skype it was a very
big deal for me so I remembered the
month and where I was and everything and
he yeah he shared with me that hit
sospiri had been a passion of his his
entire life and he wanted to make
something that was less a remake and
more reimagining and I was incredibly
excited to have the chance to work with
Luca and being a big fan of his for
years and Tilda indicator and Chloe I
think everyone's um incredible at what
they do and and no I hadn't seen the
original Suspiria and then once I landed
in Italy then I am I watched it this
this may be an obvious question but you
say you remember everything about that
because it was a big deal for you why
was it a big deal for you because Luke
is my dream director and he makes the
kinds of movies and explores the kinds
of people that I'm drawn to and so to
have the chance to just talk with him
was everything to me
Chloe what drew you to this was it Luca
Tilda the rest of the cast yeah I mean I
think obviously the the cast was was
something that just felt like I couldn't
turn that down
but the chance to to find that anonymity
to find Patricia and and to to do this
marathon of a scene which really was
kind of like a marathon and really it
was it was so it was just such a
beautiful collaborative process you know
Luke oh I think one of the first things
you said to me on the phone you're like
I want no one to know who you are I just
wanted to be like this the first you
know 15 minutes and it's this massive
splash into it and you end up hearing
what you're about to see for the rest of
the next two and a half hours you find
that all out right then but to be able
to hide that and to make it feel I don't
know is this like wonderful dance that
we did and it was just a beautiful
opportunity to collaborate and do that
and and to find that anonymity yeah I
didn't know until three days after the
movie Tilda when somebody told me I
suspect that there are many people here
how many parts did you play in the film
well if you read the poster I play madam
long that one I think they write and we
always wanted a new face to play dr.
Klemperer and we didn't want an actor
really well man nobody has any idea none
well don't tell anybody
right that's the key don't know to tell
anybody but you know there were some
little leaks that went on and so we
decided because it's so important not to
be liars right it's so important not to
deal in fake news we decided a couple of
weeks ago that we would rather spill the
beans than be seemed to be trying to
pull the wool over anybody's eyes but
the fact is that dr. Klemperer is played
by lubbers Dorf who is a psychiatrist
who lives in Berlin and is he's a
private individual and it's not really
up for any of this kind of circus and we
wanted the real deal and we got the real
deal we
did someone who wasn't I wasn't going to
give any kind of grandstanding
performance someone who was just going
to show up how much dance work did you
have to put in for this well from the
time that we started talking about the
film it was two or three years before we
shot it and then I was always kind of
when we were figuring out the dates of
shooting trying to put in enough time to
Train my body so a year before we
started filming I began working with a
woman named Mary Helen Bowers who
trained Natalie Portman for Black Swan
she does this sort of like tiny movement
workout where all your muscles get
really tight and long and it's so
intense and painful but I wanted Suzy's
body to have to appear as though she's
been dancing her whole life dancing and
also like climbing trees and being a
child so I did that on and off I trained
with a dancer who came to a set that I
was on in Vancouver when I was filming a
different film and then we spent two
weeks about a month before we started
shooting in Varese with the dancers and
Damien jelly the choreographer me and
Mia just hardcore every day learning the
choreography and then as we began
shooting and as we kind of knocked out
the dance scenes I would keep training
to do the other dance scenes that would
come up like the audition piece or
whenever we were continuing to film so
it was kind of sporadic also during
filming so on and off I trained for a
year pretty much congratulations this is
a beautiful beautiful film